bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant l'audition de Frédéric
Cuvillier le secrétaire d'État au
transport est interrogé sur le projet de
loi de réforme ferroviaire un texte qui
inquiète les syndicats et qui est à
l'origine d'un important mouvement de
grève de la SNCF depuis deux jours
Frédéric villégi campe sur ses positions
il juge indispensable cette réforme du
système ferroviaire pour sauver le rail
qui est en danger en France en danger du
fait d'une dette importante de 40
milliards d'euros le texte vise donc à
rapprocher la SNCF et RFF le
gestionnaire des infrastructures
ferroviaires et à préparer son ouverture
totale à la concurrence mais pour les
syndicats ce projet ne règle en rien le
problème de l'endettement et ne va pas
assez loin dans la réunification des
deux structures séparées en 1997 voilà
tout de suite donc on va écouter
Frédéric Cuvillier
bien bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci
à Monsieur le Ministre de d'être venu
une nouvelle fois au Sénat puisque vous
avez remarque tout à l'heure il vient
souvent au Sénat et c'est vrai que après
une phase de concertation la réforme
ferroviaire est maintenant rentrée dans
la phase parlementaire et je dirais même
dans l'actualité
la commission durable de l'Assemblée
nationale s'est prononciation l'année
dernière nos collègues députés donc
examineront le projet de loi un sens
public la semaine prochaine et de
l'autre côté nous l'examinerons donc en
commission le mercredi 25 juin prochain
et en séance début juillet
il est bon donc que nous puissions
aborder dans le détail donc cette
réforme c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons
vous entendre monsieur le ministre
mais sur cette audition intervient dans
un contexte social un peu particulier
dont tout le monde dit que vous avez la
clé la clé de
de pouvoir en quelque sorte remettre les
choses dans le bon sens mais c'est vrai
que c'est important de sur ce sujet si
vous pouvez nous dire quelques mots de
la manière dont on pourrait s'arrêter ce
conflit qui est évidemment tombe très
mal monsieur michel Teston bien sûr
notre rapporteur vous interrogera le
premier et puis après votre intervention
et puis s'il le souhaite s'il a le temps
mais peut-être ce sera pas le cas le
président François Patriat qui est ici
au titre de son rapport de la commission
des finances le fera également beaucoup
de sujets intéressent nos collègues en
particulier bien sûr le problème de la
dette que nous avons longuement abordé
au cours des deux auditions précédentes
nous avons donc
auditionné monsieur Guillaume Pépi
Monsieur Jacques Rapoport ce matin et
bien sûr ces sujets ont été abordés mais
nous espérons aussi que vous pourrez
nous donner quelques informations un
autre sujet important la place des
régions dans ce dispositif avec deux
éléments d'actualité comment va
s'articuler ce texte avec celui de la
territoriale notamment la refonte des
cartes des régions où en est-on de
l'avancement des volets de mobilité dans
les futurs contrats de projets bien sûr
sont des sujets d'actualité sur lesquels
beaucoup s'interrogent et enfin toujours
en matière d'aménage en territoire
quelle est la position du Gouvernement
sur le maintien et la réhabilitation des
lignes secondaires qui contribuent au
désenclamment des territoires tout court
et des territoires ruraux et comment
développer la mobilité d'une manière
plus durable voilà donc les quelques
questions que nous avons recueilli
discuter et bien sûr nous attendant
monsieur le ministre que vous puissiez
nous en parler avec
la franchise et la compétence dont vous
avez toujours fait preuve quand vous
êtes venus ici au Sénat voilà monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole vous
savez une bonne demi-heure
si vous le voulez plus si vous en avez
besoin et
tous très conscients de l'importance de
ce débat
ce matin des mots très forts ont été
employés donc sur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président c'est un porteur
mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices de
sénateurs merci pour votre indulgence
d'abord et pour les propos
agréables entendre surtout lorsqu'on est
en charge de transport
et que l'actualité
est quotidienne est souvent actualités
sociales peut-être un mot sur cette
actualité pour faire le point de ce que
les inquiétudes elles sont
exprimées sous des formes différentes un
certain nombre d'organisations ont
décidé
d'engager une grève reconductible
d'autres au contraire n'ont souhaité
poursuivre le dialogue qui ne veut pas
dire d'ailleurs que lorsqu'on est
grève il n'y a pas de dialogue loi sans
faut mais sous des formes différentes et
j'ai indiqué que leur même que nous
sommes en contact depuis plus d'un an et
demi avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales nous serions alors
disposition
dès ce soir j'ai anticipé j'avais donné
rendez-vous
aux organisations syndicales avant même
que ce préavis de grève ne soit
lancée et exercer mais j'ai anticipé
autant que de besoin cette rencontre qui
sera ce soir à tour d'horizon de la
situation et qui se poursuivra demain
demain matin demain après-midi peut-être
au-delà si c'est nécessaire en tout cas
je me rendrai le plus largement
disponible pour pouvoir relever les
défis et c'est important de
l'explication de ce projet de loi
maintenant le Parlement et votre
assemblée mais également saisie
sera appelé
à faire évoluer ce texte ce que j'ai
d'ailleurs indiqué aux organisations
syndicales la procédure législative elle
est aussi là pour enrichir amender par
nature et améliorer autant que deux
besoins donc je n'ai pas là de
soucis
de susceptibilité d'auteur au contraire
je pense que la corrélation surtout
lorsqu'elle est parlementaire
est nécessaire pour pouvoir avoir un
texte qui soit le plus opérationnel sur
des orientations qui sont
désorientations visant à renforcer le
service public et de peut-être préciser
parce que j'ai entendu beaucoup de
choses des reportages sur les lieux de
grève
qu'il n'y a pas il n'y a pas pour objet
dans ce texte de
privatisation ou de libéralisation c'est
un sujet et un débat voire même un
combat qui se mène ailleurs je ferai le
point dans quelques secondes de cette de
ce contexte européen rappelez-vous que
le gouvernement avait de ses premiers
jours indiqués qu'il n'anticiperait pas
la libéralisation telle que voulu par
l'Europe et que dans la discussion du
quatrième paquet ferroviaire je
reviendrai au contraire nous
souhaiterions et nous souhaitions et
nous souhaitons faire en sorte que la
voix de la France soit portée haut sur
la spécificité de l'organisation
ferroviaire je reviendrai donc c'est un
premier point et d'autre part la
question des statuts dont on dit qu'elle
serait
indirectement
contenu dans ce texte non ce qui est une
réalité c'est prenant exemple et appuie
sur une expérience malheureuse de
libéralisation mal préparée du fret
qui ne traitait pas la question des
conditions
salariales nous avions et nous avons
aujourd'hui un frais de ferroviaire qui
est malgré
la présence d'une vingtaine d'opérateurs
différents avec des statuts totalement
différents eux-mêmes avec des règles qui
ne sont pas
harmonisées et surtout avec des
conditions de dialogue social qui ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer de sorte que ce
que nous souhaitons et nous leur
envoyons après au dialogue au dialogue
social à la discussion c'est qu'il
existe qui se mettent en place devant la
multiplicité des opérateurs ferroviaires
et ça que ce qu'augmenter qu'il y est
une convention collective applicable à
l'ensemble de l'activité ferroviaire
c'est indispensable sinon il y a
distorsion signons il y a une
concurrence qui sera
effectivement là au moment où elle
j'ai parlé très rapidement du quatrième
paquet peut-être ferroviaire peut-être
puis-je donner d'entrer le jeu cette
dimension européenne vous vous souvenez
d'ailleurs ici même un certain nombre de
questions m'avaient été posées il y a
deux ans sur la compatibilité de notre
projet de loi qui n'en était que
première esquisses et les premières
rédactions et notamment sur le fait que
nous aurions nous serions rattraperré
rattrapés par le quatrième paquet
ferroviaire
et que celui-ci nous imposerait un
modèle d'organisation il n'en est rien
et je l'avais d'ailleurs indiqué devant
votre commission
qu'il était important que nous puissions
obtenir de la page de l'Europe une forme
de reconnaissance du principe de
subsidiarité quant à l'organisation même
des systèmes ferroviaires c'est vrai
pour la France c'est vrai d'autres pays
et cette position a été rejoint par un
certain nombre d'acteurs européens qui
tirant
conséquence d'une de ce qu'est le
ferroviaire c'est à dire une évolution
une construction de l'État même du
domaine du patrimoine de l'État il
fallait que nous puissions avoir une
Europe du transport et particulièrement
du ferroviaire qui permettent d'avoir de
des réseaux à la dimension européenne et
que nous puissions être efficace sur
cette interopérabilité nécessaire sur
des frontières souvent techniques ou de
réglementation qui doivent tomber mais
que l'organisation n'était pas celle qui
devait être commandée par une forme de
pensée unique qui est la pensée unique
du commissaire Calas c'est Calas
leumbolding cher à son dogme qui serait
la séparation absolue étanche un peu
anticipé en 97 par la loi de 97 et on
envoie les conséquences nous avons aussi
discuté beaucoup au niveau européen je
le dis parce que le paquet politique
quatrième paquet ferroviaire que l'on
m'agité comme une forme d'épouvantail
non seulement n'a pas été votée sur le
gouvernance pas encore et pas avant à
mon sens 2015 mais en plus et donc
l'intérêt est grand de pouvoir avoir
nous-mêmes une législation qui influence
et qui pèse sur l'organisation
européenne de demain et par ailleurs la
question du financement par le
gestionnaire d'infrastructures ou au
profit des gestionnaires
d'infrastructures étaient une une
question extrêmement importante je crois
pouvoir dire mais j'aurai l'occasion
d'être plus précis lors des débats que
le modèle que nous pouvons mettre en
place permet de
d'assurer une forme de contribution à le
financement des infrastructures par le
transporteur et en l'occurrence ce sera
SNCF mobilité au même titre que d'autres
permettant ainsi de réduire le fardeau
de la dette c'est un enjeu qui était un
enjeu indispensable parce que l'Europe
dans un premier temps souhaitait au
contraire que l'on coupe les liens
capitalistiques ou financiers entre les
différentes entités mais dans le sens du
soutien à l'infrastructure contrairement
à d'autres pays qui au contraire par
l'infrastructure finance le transporteur
nous avons de ce point de vue
je crois pleine
reconnaissance de leur recompatibilité
de cette logique qui est une logique de
préservation du bien commun du
patrimoine commun c'est-à-dire
l'infrastructure trop souvent trop
longtemps négligé doit être la priorité
y compris dans les modes de financement
voilà pourquoi
cette question et cette combat
cette discussion
au niveau européen était extrêmement
élevé encore sensible et qu'il fallait
mener de front cette enjeu parce que
nous ne pouvions pas ne pas compter
comme ce fut trop longtemps le cas sur
la spécificité ferroviaire ne pas porter
notre conception même de la réalité du
service public des obligations de
service public j'ai encore dit à mon
homologue monsieur loopy lors du dernier
ministre italien des transports et qui
va sur la présidence pour les 6
prochains mois que l'on ne pouvait
AB la question de la gouvernance
et donc d'une forme de libéralisation
dans le calendrier sans dans le même
temps et préalablement que l'on
définisse les obligations de services
publics parce que dans ce cas vous
auriez des attributions et nous avons
combien lorsqu'il n'y a pas de cadre
prétabli répondant à ce qui se trouve
être des enjeux d'aménagement du
territoire d'équilibre des
investissements nous aurions alors des
formes de privatisation ou de
libéralisation sur des lignes rentables
et au contraire une nationalisation au
sens large avec les collectivités avec
l'État sur des lignes qui sautent des
lignes qui n'ont pas le trafic suffisant
pour être rentable donc le cadre de
l'obligation de service public est
extrêmement importante c'est vrai que
nous ne sommes pas nombreux au niveau
européen à défendre cette conception
mais lorsque la France et lorsqu'elle
est soutenue et respectée par ses
partenaires posent le problème de cette
de nécessité de reconnaissance de la
spécificité même du service public de
cet enjeu d'intérêt général alors elle
est écoutée mais elle est écoutée à
condition qu'elle ne plaît pas en
interne une séparation je rencontrais
mon prédécesseur à l'instant en question
d'actualité l'Assemblée nationale lui
indiquant combien sa vision séparatiste
avait fait du mal non seulement par les
dysfonctionnements parce que c'est là
au-delà de l'enjeu européen ce qui nous
préoccupe de pouvoir assurer ce qui est
une attente des cheminots mais c'est une
attente
a prioritairement des usagers des
collectivités des régions qui financent
largement le ferroviaire que séparatisme
avait amené à des dysfonctionnements et
il n'est jamais
jamais une mauvaise chose que de
reconnaître des erreurs ou des voix qui
n'amenaient pas vers la réussite
aujourd'hui ce qui est attendu c'est du
confort c'est de la régularité c'est de
l'entretien des voies c'est
une stratégie et précisément ce que nous
souhaitons c'est que nous puissions
organiser une véritable et rendre aussi
ce débat là qui est légitime
représentant de la nation que sont les
parlementaires que nous puissions avoir
une stratégie de définie pour la nation
une stratégie du ferroviaire avec
régulièrement un rendu de d'étape et
d'un contrôle ce pourquoi l'État qui
était absent considérant que la
politique ferroviaire devait être opérée
par la seule SNCF elle-même séparée dans
ses fonctions et bien nous avons
souhaité remettre la légitimité au
niveau du Parlement par la nécessité de
présenter
l'orientation de la politique
ferroviaire et puis par la composition
des organes directeurs j'y reviendrai
dans quelques instants présence de
l'État réaffirmé elle n'est qu'un tiers
du conseil d'administration actuelle de
la SNCF ce n'est pas suffisant elle doit
être majoritaire cette présence de
l'état des régions qui aujourd'hui
réclament légitimement un certain nombre
de reconnaissance et
de transparence dans la façon dont les
choses sont réglées et il est vrai que
dans l'évolution y compris des de la
décentralisation et de la carte
territoriale il faut que les régions
puissent puisqu'elles financent déjà et
puisque la clarificielle des compétences
viendra à leur
transmettre
ne pas plus importante de la compétence
sur les transports et bien qu'elle soit
aussi des acteurs de ce grand défi de la
modernisation du du transport
ferroviaire alors nous devons améliorer
la qualité du service public
nous devons maîtriser également
sa trajectoire financière nous devons
aborder la question du cadre social ou
en tout cas les grandes règles
permettant d'assurer les lieux et moyens
du dialogue social et il faut pour cela
que nous puissions avoir un système qui
ne soit pas handicapé par la gouvernance
le handicap de la gouvernance c'est
d'avoir des missions qui sont des
missions éclatées alors même qu'elles
doivent être rassemblées et ces missions
je pense
l'infrastructure qui aujourd'hui se
trouve être une organisation assez
étrange tellement étrange que y compris
les gens du ferroviaire c'est aussi
retrouvent peu entre la DCF entre la
SNCF Infra qui eux-mêmes interviennent à
la demande des rêves laquelle RF
représente 1500 agents sur 150
agent de la famille cheminotte c'est
dire combien il nous faut simplifier
tout simplement et faire que nous
puissions avoir un secteur public une
entreprise publique unifiée qui
elle-même clarifie l'émission en son
sein deux établissements publics qui
seront d'une part pour simplifier
beaucoup plus complexe et ainsi sans
filiales SNCF mais deux grands corps de
métiers l'infrastructure la gestion de
l'infrastructure et
le la mobilité par SNCF mobilité bien
sûr allez-vous me dire mais nous sommes
dans un contexte où l'ouverture d'un
certain nombre de marchés
devra assurer des règles du jeu qui
souhaitent des règles du jeu transparent
dans l'attribution des sillons dans le
respect des différents intervenants bref
ce que l'on appelle les missions
essentielles la tarification et il est
évident que le régulateur aura sa
mission mais faut-il parce que
certaines fonctions dites essentielles
doivent être exercées sans emprise de la
part de la SNCF mobilité éclater un
système alors même que nous avons besoin
d'avoir des personnes qui travaillent
dans la même direction dans le même sens
avec la même volonté là où pendant des
années on leur a appris à ne pas
collaborer à ne pas se rencontrer et
jouer de la défiance je souhaite donc
renforcer le secteur public avec vous
donner à la nation
les moyens de définir sa stratégie
ferroviaire je faisais référence placer
l'État en état stratège avec des moyens
de financer et de piloter les acteurs
publics et mettre fin à l'enchevêtrement
des responsabilités c'est une nécessité
et pour ça il faut ce sera peut-être la
première fois depuis de très longues
années que nous aborderons ce sujet il
nous faut prendre à bras le corps la
question de la dette
et
des
réalités de cet endettement 40 milliards
aujourd'hui d'endettement car près de 2
milliards et demi à 3 milliards
d'accroissements automatiques de la
dette sans un travaux supplémentaire
accroissement automatique de la dette
qui vient bien évidemment opérer toute
forme de
d'efficacité de cette organisation ça
veut dire que si nous ne faisons rien
c'est une question de responsabilité je
le dirai ce soir aux organisations
syndicales si nous ne faisons rien et je
pourrais être comme d'autres
en considérant que des successeurs parce
qu'ils sont successeurs sont plus malins
que soi-même et donc auront plus de
compétences et de capacité à apporter
des réponses
à des sujets qui nous ont fait que
croître et n'ont pas embellir pour le
coup mais au contraire se durcir dans la
prise en compte de la réalité non il
nous faut non pas transmettre aux
générations qui viennent par un manque
de courage politique je sais que cette
question est difficile à aborder je sais
combien il y a des forces antagonistes
et contradictoires mais je sais aussi
que si nous n'assumons pas cela si nous
n'ayons pas de travailler tous ensemble
collectivités acteurs du ferroviaire
organisation syndicale à rétablir une
perspective du secteur ferroviaire alors
nous d'abord n'assumons pas nos
responsabilités mais aussi nous ne nous
donnons pas de perspective d'avenir au
ferroviaire si nous ne faisons rien dans
10 ans ce sont 80 milliards
d'euros de déficit certains disent mais
il faut que l'État prenne à son compte
la dette mais je ne ferai pas usage
d'une éponge magique qui pourrait
automatiquement
effacer cette dette d'abord parce que ce
serait pas vertueux mais par ailleurs
parce que je n'en ai pas le pouvoir et
que le ministère des Transports n'est
pas encore situé assez près de la scène
pour pouvoir prendre des décisions à
caractère
ça compte aussi mais prenons en compte
cette réalité et elle n'est pas mince la
réalité politique il faut toujours
l'intégrer pour en faire plutôt un atout
que un inconvénient et une faiblesse
elle me dit que c'est l'occasion pour
nous de démontrer que l'objectif
est celui de la stabilisation de la
dette si ne faisons pas des réformes de
structure madame la ministre j'ai
plaisir à vous saluer si
nous ne faisons pas ces réformes si nous
ne stabilisons pas la dette alors il ne
sera pas de bonne administration de
bonne économie et de bonnes gestion que
de demander à l'État automatiquement
d'intervenir sur des dettes aussi
importantes faisons la démonstration de
l'efficacité du secteur ferroviaire
faisons les réformes de structures
nécessaires donnant de la compétitivité
et ça n'est pas un gros mot donnant de
la compétitivité de la productivité au
secteur ferroviaire et donnant lui les
moyens de pouvoir
relever ce défi et surtout supprimer ce
fardeau un certain nombre de
dispositions sont mises en œuvre et j'y
reviendrai en répondant plutôt à vos
questions
nous avons donc la nécessité de répondre
à un danger plus large que l'opérateur
historique parce que je ne veux pas que
l'on considère que notre travail et
votre mission qui sera la mission
législative ne concerne qu'une réforme
de la SNCF ou du groupe SNCF il s'agit
bien de l'ensemble du ferroviaire et
lorsque je dis que la nécessité pour
nous est devant une stratégie
ferroviaire c'est précisément parce que
la stratégie ferroviaire elle passe
aussi par l'ensemble des acteurs du
ferroviaire c'est dans ce sens que le
projet de loi crée un Haut Comité du
ferroviaire permettant aux parties
prenantes états région entreprises
ferroviaire usagées que l'on doit
entendre organisateur à organisation
syndicale de débattre des stratégies
nécessaires de la stratégie nationale du
l'ensemble du système ferroviaire et
puis je répondrai bien sûr à vos
questions sur le lien le lien de ce à
l'intérieur de ce groupe public
ferroviaire fort contrôlé par l'État par
les personnes publiques je le dis parce
qu'on me dit j'entends que le projet de
loi serait l'éclatement de la SNCF en
trois entités il y a trois entités bien
sûr qu'il y a 3 entités il y a en tout
cas deux entités sous une entité qui est
l'antiquité de la stratégie de la
réunification de la décision et du
pilotage de ferroviaire vous avez un
groupe et un groupe c'est plusieurs
entités en effet mais qui sont des
entités reliées ce sont des entités qui
sont
n'ont pas autonomes comme certains
souhaiteraient les avoir mais au
contraire relié avec un lien fort qui
permette de donner des directions à
l'organisation et de ce point de vue je
ferai je le dis et je compte sur les
amendements
des parlementaires en sorte que nous
ayons un groupe et je le dirai aux
organisations médical ce soir
un groupe qui puisse avoir des liens
avec ces établissements publics dont
lesquels dépendent du groupe de tête des
liens suffisamment
serrés pour que ne puisse pas revenir
sur cette organisation
au bénéfice d'une malheureuse alternance
qui si elle devait intervenir
ce que nous souhaitons pas
mais non parce que j'avais si vous avez
la grève existe de façon massive aussi
c'est parce qu'il y a eu des voix
qui se sont élevés et qui ont dit mais
lorsque nous allons revenir nous
couperons le lien entre l'entité mère et
les deux entités filles et bien j'ai
entendu ce message et cette prévention
et qui me renforce dans la nécessité de
renforcer ses liens de sorte que il ne
puisse y avoir ni opération de ciseaux
ou de tenaille mais au contraire qu'il y
ait un groupe public ferroviaire qui
s'inscrivent dans le temps et dans la
stabilité et c'est indispensable donc de
ce point de vue merci de nous avoir
prévenu des
parfois
songent
qui inquiète et qui serait de mauvaises
gestion c'est cela par malheur devait
arriver et donc nous ferons tout pour
qu'il n'en soit pas assis
je reviendrai selon vos questions
l'organisation le Directoire le
président de SNCF
mobilité et SNCF Infra au sein d'un
directoire un conseil d'administration
les directeurs pardon de cette CFA SNCF
mobilité qui constitueront le Directoire
et puis un président du conseil de
surveillance qui sera nommé par l'État
et qui aura à non seulement
exécuter l'organisme les orientations du
conseil de surveillance mais également
en cas de
désaccord de trancher les questions
stratégiques et de donner là encore
pleine mesure de cette intégration
je puis vous parler
mais je pense qu'il est préférable que
ce soit par sous la forme de question on
risque d'être trop
trop long et barbative mais à la fois de
ce que la RAF aura comme mission
fixé par décret
enfin de mission qui seront prévues par
la loi et
des
contrôles qui seront exercés par l par
ce régulateur par lui donc notamment sur
le ratio de la dette sur la
soutenabilité financière du contrat
entre l'État et la SNCF réseau bref un
véritable rôle de régulateur qui sera
nécessaire de conforter contrairement à
ce que j'ai pu lire ailleurs de ce
projet de loi dont l'encre n'était pas
même sèche qu'il était sur un certain
nombre de dispositions déjà mis en cause
à tort puisque l'encre si elle n'était
pas sèche n'était donc pas lisible ça
n'est précisément pas le sens d'un
régulateur limité
un régulateur
contrariée dans ses compétences mais
bien d'un régulateur qui assume la
pertinence de l'ensemble de
l'organisation on également des
questions sociales sur la nécessité de
créer les conditions d'un cadre social
modernisé un décret socle qui posera les
principales règles communes pour le
secteur ferroviaire notamment regarde
des exigences de sécurité de continuité
de service public
le système et la négociation de
conventions collective nationale qui
s'appliquera à l'ensemble des
entreprises de la branche ferroviaire
épique mais aussi autre opérateurs
ferroviaires donc aider négociations
d'entreprises là où ce sera engagé devra
être engagé dans l'ensemble de ces
entreprises avec cette clarification des
relations et des cadres la mise en place
des cadres de dialogues sociales nous
assurons ce qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui
des dispositifs permettant d'avoir un
cadre social commun des règles sociales
communes et surtout d'avoir la
possibilité d'éviter qu'il n'y ait des
distorsions qui souhaitent des
distorsions pour le coup social au
détriment d'opérateurs qui eux-mêmes ont
la charge du service public voilà
quelques je pense qu'il faut que je me
taise pour les bas provisant
bien merci merci pour cette introduction
de ce débat donc la parole est donnée à
Monsieur michel Teston et à François
Patriat il peut rester un petit moment
voilà Michel dit monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci d'avoir
présenté de manière claire les
principaux aspects du projet de loi de
réforme ferroviaire quant à moi fidèle à
une tradition que j'ai mise en place
déjà depuis quelques auditions sur ce
sujet je ne poserai que quatre questions
ce qui permettra aux autres membres de
la commission de pouvoir s'exprimer
largement
première question elle porte sur la
nécessité à mon sens de mettre l'accent
sur le caractère intégré du futur groupe
SNCF ce qui suppose l'intégration
sociale
et cette question bien évidemment est au
cœur de l'actualité alors pour moi
l'intégration suppose un
d'affirmer la compétence exclusive de
l’épic de tête en matière de gestion
statutaire
c'est un aspect fondamental mais une
bonne intégration sociale passe aussi
par l'affirmation de l'unité du groupe
alors à ce sujet
il me semble que la mise en place
d'un comité central entreprise
pourrait notamment y contribuer ce n'est
pas le seul aspect mais je me limiterai
à donner cette indication sur l'état de
mes réflexions à la matière alors sans
toutefois dévoiler monsieur ministre je
viens de vous le demande pas surtout pas
ce que vous pourrez dire ce soir et
demain aux représentants syndicaux
pensez-vous qu'il soit souhaitable de
renforcer le projet de loi dans ce sens
là c'est important bien sûr pour le
rapporteur que je suis ici au Sénat
important de savoir quel est votre avis
sur cette question de l'intégration
sociale deuxième question
elle porte c'est aussi d'actualité sur
l'inquiétude des cheminots en matière de
maintien de leur statut et de la future
organisation du travail alors je
rappelle qu'il n'a jamais été question
dans ce projet de loi de remettre en
cause le statut des cheminots par contre
s'agissant de l'organisation du travail
il y a une large concertation qui est en
cours sur l'autorité de Monsieur
Bessières et donc il me semble au
porteur là aussi dans le contexte actuel
d'affirmer que la harmonisation à la
matière ne peut être que par le haut
pouvez-vous nous dire
quelque chose à ce stade chercher sujet
parce que c'est un sujet également
important troisième question
elle concerne la situation financière du
système ferroviaire on sait très bien
qu'on ne peut pas rester dans la
situation actuelle
dans quelle mesure l'état
participera-t-il à cet effort alors il y
a diverses hypothèses il y a la question
de la dette d'État il y a la question
du dividende
lorsqu'il existe
pardon du dividende lorsqu'il y a un
résultat donc à SNCF mobilité et puis il
y a effectivement ce que l'État pourrait
également accepter de ne pas percevoir
comme recette notamment fiscale
quatrième et dernière question la place
des régions alors ici le rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des finances c'est
mieux placée que moi pour évoquer la
place des régions bien qu'il
interviennent sinon pas en tant que
président de région mais en tant que
rapporteur de la commission des finances
donc je me permettrais malgré tout
François de dire quelques mots à ce
sujet
comment voyez-vous monsieur le ministre
sur leur place dans la nouvelle
organisation tant en ce qui considère le
transport de voyageurs que le réseau
c'est la question de la représentation
des régions au conseil d'administration
de l’épique de tête mais aussi au CA de
SNCF réseau il est pas question qu'il
soit aussi ADSL mobilité puisque si un
jour il y avait
je ne le demande pas moi l'ouverture à
la concurrence bien évidemment ça serait
impossible pour les régions d'être dans
le CA d'un des exploitants ferroviaires
il y a aussi la question de la propriété
des matériaux c'est une question que
pose un juste titre les régions et puis
il y a la question de la liberté de
tarification j'arrête là parce que les
questions posées par nos collègues élus
régionaux sont plus nombreuses mais j'ai
promis ne pas être trop long donc je
m'arrête là monsieur le Président
michel Teston alors Monsieur François
Patriat puis en plus on demandera un
ministre de vous répondre vous puissiez
écouter la réponse monsieur Patriot
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
de m'avoir invité de m'accueillir comme
ce matin
à la suite monsieur le ministre une
réunion qui a été fort intéressante ce
matin de la part du sur apoport sur la
dette sur les objectifs sur les moyens
sur les
sur les difficultés et sur les priorités
qui imposent à RFF
où sont à poster des choix notamment en
matière de très grande vitesse par
rapport au musée ce matin avec 300
millions d'euros par an tout le système
secondaire fonctionne bien j'aimerais
bien je n'ai pas repris sur ce sujet
après mais j'aimerais bien tant les
sommes qui sont demandées aujourd'hui
collectivités et qui sont engagés par
vous même je l'espère d'ailleurs dans
les futurs contrats de projets dont j'ai
cru comprendre qu'il comportera un volet
mobilité et que la seule priorité serait
le réseau ferroviaire alors je veux
parler si au nom des régions
mais vous dire simplement que si les
régions demain sont en responsabilité
pour être celle qui gérer les stratégies
mais aussi les transports ça demandera
des moyens comme le demande aujourd'hui
l'entité SNCF en tout cas de la des
transports publics que nous voulons
créer
par heure donc on voit on voit
aujourd'hui le challenge que vous
proposez quand il faut stabiliser la
dette j'ai entendu certaines de nos
collègues ce matin c'est bon dire que
même si la bonne volonté était là il n'y
croyait pas même nous on espère parce
que nous soutenons ce projet et que nous
souhaitons que demain les erreurs du
passé qui ont fait que il y a des
difficultés vous savez quand
le président de Région interroge
Guillaume Pépi et qui lui dit mais
comment se fait-il que la convention
augmente comme ça me dit mais ce
Président c'est pas moi c'est les péages
qui augmentent et je voulais répercute
comme une répercute d'ailleurs y compris
la retraite des agents de la SNCF etc
nous le fait tout le temps je répercute
qu'on impose la loi donc on peut pas se
renvoyer comme ça les responsabilités
d'où l'intérêt d'ailleurs de sexe de loi
qui va permettre d'avoir une entité
unique où les responsabilités comme les
engagements seront partagés et ce que
nous approuvons totalement
donc si demain il doit y avoir des
engagements avec les collectivités il
faudra bien ce ministre qu'on soit
d'accord sur les compétences des régions
c'est un aparté mais aussi le ressources
parce que demander aujourd'hui au
collectivités de payer les voies d'eau
de payer la voie ferrée de payer les
routes quand elles sont pas compétentes
voilà j'entends bien et de faire marcher
les trains avec
00 1 centime de TIPP qui n'a rien à voir
avec le train ça peut pas fonctionner
comme ça longtemps donc il faudra si
avec clarification des compétences qui
aussi le rééducation des ressources
c'est un autre sujet mais je sais parce
que j'en ai souvent parlé avec vous que
vous y êtes sensible bon
je vais pas vous poser beaucoup de
questions parce que je vais devoir
partir à la commission des finances sur
le PFR qui siège à la même je voudrais
interroger aussi les ministres
pensez-vous qu'on pourra réellement
stabiliser la dette à quel niveau dans
les cinq ans
faut-il mais vous avez déjà répondu à la
question
faut-il que l'État reprenne une partie
de la dette parce que on a créé un outil
avec un puits qui est déjà trouve du
pétrole aujourd'hui tellement c'est
profond alors on lui avait créé tome tel
vous avez le parfum répondu ça ne
changera rien à la donne il reste que
RFF porte ce poids aujourd'hui et que
peut-être le porter parce que c'est pas
compris dans la dette de l'État j'ai
compris hein
c'est pas au total c'est la moitié non
c'est pas compris donc je vois bien
l'intérêt mais
est-ce qu'on pourrait faire un peu mieux
c'est la petite la seule question pour
là vous avez dit qu'on j'ai compris
qu'on devait gagner un milliard moi j'ai
défendu ce test devant les médias en
début de semaine
500 millions pour l'une et l'autre des
entités c'est déjà bien vous avez
annoncé le chiffre vous avez dit 80 ou
79 hier ça paraissait un peu démesuré ce
matin aux auteurs que nous avons
rencontrés par ailleurs mais voilà c'est
sur la dette un peu je voulais vous
interroger en disant allez pensez-vous
réellement même si on économise améliore
qu'on pourra stabiliser la dette dans 5
ans à quel niveau et à ce qu'on pourrait
pas sur la dette future un peu soulagé
quand même le type pour pouvoir qu'il
soit plus efficace demain voilà merci
Monsieur mini merci
répondre à ces deux interlocuteurs
peut-être commencer par les
préoccupations régionales régionales je
vais pas dire régionaliste mais des
représentants des régions
sur la place plus précisément des
régions dans le système ferroviaire
c'est vrai que il est temps de
saisir l'opportunité de ce projet de loi
de réforme ferroviaire pour
donner plein de mesures à la
photographie même de l'organisation et
du financement du ferroviaire et je
comprends même si j'en étais victime pas
violentée mais je comprends les
réactions des présidents de région se
tournant vers le ministre
interpellant président de la SNCF
président des FF en disant mais nous
nous participons au financement du
ferroviaire et de quelle manière
filière industrielle de la même façon
donc dans la gouvernance pour y revenir
la réalité
de la participation aux financement et à
la définition des politiques de
transport qui sera accrue dans le projet
de décentralisation qui vous est soumis
amen ce que à la fois dans mais je
réponds en même temps à michel Teston à
la fois dans le
conseil de surveillance
de l'Épic de tête donc dans la structure
de tête il y aura des sièges de sièges
réservés aux régions et ce sera
également le cas dans le conseil
d'administration
de l'Épic SNCF réseau initialement dans
les pic de tête ça n'était pas prévu
d'abord parce que il faut bien faire
attention à ce que ça ne touche pas
des questions liées à la SNCF mobilité
le jour venu
aujourd'hui
cette la présence elle est légitime mais
nous appartiendrons nous appartiendra
d'organiser le moment venu
la participation sans qu'il y a
d'interférences avec les enjeux de la
SNCF mobilité nous avons également nos
étudiants mais en fait nous étudions
favorablement
ça vous permet d'avoir un état d'esprit
les demandes qui sont les demandes
émanant de région concernant la
propriété du matériel roulant
cette discussion que nous avons eu en
commission à l'Assemblée nationale que
nous manquerons pas d'abord ici
simplement aujourd'hui je le disais vos
collègues de l'Assemblée la propriété du
matériel roulant elle était elle est
conçue comme bien de retour
encore faut-il que ce ne soit pas une
forme d'anticipation à la libéralisation
parce que ça n'a de sens que s'il s'agit
de remettre à disposition en fin de
contrats
du matériel roulant à disposition
d'autres opérateurs et nous ne sommes
pas dans ce cadre-là pour autant c'est
vrai les régions financent par le biais
de la SNCF alors peut-être par
intermédiaire de la SNCF il y a
certainement une
là une évolution
à apporter parce qu'il est légitime que
lorsqu'on achète quelque chose ce soit
pas celui qui l'achète en votre nom qui
en soit propriétaire c'est une forme de
voilà
c'est vrai aussi la propriété des biens
immobiliers mais de ce point de vue nous
avons encore à progresser sur ces
questions et de la liberté tarifaire je
sais que c'est une revendication
jamais et c'est mon rôle
quelques bémols cette liberté tarifaire
elle doit malgré tout garantir
l'existence de tarification sociale qui
doivent être des tarifices sociales
nationales donc
sous réserve en tout cas c'est
aujourd'hui l'État du texte après un
désaccord courtois mais des accords
malgré tout qui aboutit à forme
de consensus de négociation
d'un texte
reconnaissant ou tendant vers la
reconnaissance à une liberté tarifaire
sous réserve de du maintien des tarifs
sociaux et d'un certain nombre de taxes
présents contre par l'État au nom de la
région mais tout cela aura
taxe de quai
redevance d'accès alors je sais que ça
fait débat lorsque par l'argent ça fait
toujours débat et lorsque l'on veut
pleine compétences il faut que l'on ait
pleine clarification de quiper quoi au
nom de qui et pour faire quoi
voilà donc les avancées sur cette
question pour ce qui est de l'équilibre
financier mais peut-être
l'équilibre financier le constat c'est
de toute façon les chiffres sont
apparables c'est vrai qu'ils sont
éloquents
n'avait pas en tête celui d'un million
par jour ou par heure 500 millions par
jour 500 millions par mois
c'est dire il faut qu'on aille vite
c'est pour ça peut-être que le texte a
été déclaré en urgence
et que nous arrivions vite un texte voté
conforme qu'on a commencé ça fait donc
depuis ce matin beaucoup de cher au
système ferroviaire
vous gagnez du temps
active
donc une dette qui progresse
annuellement alors selon que l'on
intègre ou non les lignes LGV sans
esprit de polémique mais en réalité tout
de même puisque c'est une réalité que
l'on doit assumer les lignes LGV
qui ont été engagés concomitamment
4 alors même que la soutenabilité
financière était d'une ligne LGV tous
les 5 6 ans 4 lignes LGV
lancé quasiment dans le même période et
bien nous laisser le ferroviaire d'une
façon insurmontable alors tant mieux
pour ceux qui sont bénéficiaires de la
grande vitesse encore faut-il qu'elle
ait un sens mais ça c'est un autre débat
et c'est un débat de la stratégie
ferroviaire que le Parlement devra avoir
actuellement il n'y a pas ce lieu de
débat et cette ce rendez-vous nécessaire
donc il y a des projections après
échange avec la SNCF avec RFF l'état oui
monsieur le rapporteur viendra
porter
sa contribution notamment par le
reversement des dividendes
vers le gestionnaire unique
d'infrastructures donc abandonnera c'est
évident
c'est quand même 500 millions et
permettra donc la consolidation au
niveau du groupe des déficits de fiscaux
et cette consolidation sera intégrée
dans le prochain collectif budgétaire
les gains de production améliore
organisation la politique d'achat les
fonctions supports devraient permettre à
la SNCF mobilité
d'organiser un plan qui serait un plan
change jusqu'à gain d'un milliard nous
soutient la SNCF je retiens le chiffre
et pour sa part SNCF réseau
évoque un plan de performance et de
synergie de l'ordre de 900 millions
alors c'est vrai que ce sont
des enjeux difficiles
à atteindre les il faut que l'on puisse
s'emporter tous garants pour ça
d'ailleurs que je fais d'autant plus à
l'aise que cette invitation que il est
important je réponds à cela à transition
vers des questions de michel Teston
cadre social discussion
les organisations syndicales savent très
bien l'état du ferroviaire
et au-delà de cette période qui sera une
période un peu
agitée de la discussion c'est normal
chacun a ses idées du débat je crois
vraiment qu'elle savent là où il y a des
gains de
d'efficacité de productivité de
politique commerciale
ne savent très bien sur le fret ce qui
peut être mieux organisé d'ailleurs à
participer au groupe de travail que je
lançais et les organisations syndicales
représentant des salariés sont souvent
avec des propositions qui elles-mêmes
peuvent être génératrices de meilleures
résultats économiques du groupe donc
je sais pas pour une culture
d'affrontement c'est pour une culture de
partage d'objectifs cet objectif là
j'aimerais qu'il soit partagé par tous
et que ce soit pas monsieur Pepy
monsieur Rapoport monsieur Cuvillier qui
viennent vous livrer ces chiffres
moi parce qu'on les a donnés parce
qu'ils les ont calculé mais que ce soit
à partir de ces chiffres une oeuvre
collective permettant de sauver le
ferroviaire donc dans ce cadre-là
il est souhaitable que nous puissions
avoir des lieux et peut-être même un
suivi nous verrons avec les
organisations syndicales comment elles
abordent la suite de cette réforme pour
assurer l'effectivité dans la difficulté
est grande
j'ai été incomplet sur la dette mais
avant de revenir sur la question
syndicale
c'est vrai que toute la dette
sera pas
diminuée par une stabilisation par
nature mais dans un déjà
si nous ne réglons pas ce problème de
l'accroissement de la dette il faut
savoir que et du traitement de la dette
qui doit être je l'ai dit dans mon
propos liminaire par étape traitement de
la dette après stabilisation y compris
organisationnelle effectivement
efficacité de l'organisation
c'est le contribuable qui sera appelé
nous souhaitons pas que le contribuable
soit appelé à cela mais pour autant de
l'ordre de 10 milliards de dettes
vient d'être
Maastricht je sais pas comment on va
dire le maastrichisé en tout cas
voilà des milliards des milliards de
dettes des FF sur les 37 qui sont
considérés comme dette qualifiée de
dettes maastrichienne
et donc qui amènera à ce que l'effort
collectif de la nation et c'est le bien
de la nation vous n'avez pas de dire
c'est vrai c'est le bien de la nation
c'est le bien de chacun d'entre nous
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs y compris dans
le débat parlementaire pour y avoir des
évolutions sur la garantie du patrimoine
national ferroviaire
peut-être alors je dis ça généralement
ils sont au cabinet est inquiets ou la
DGTM sont toujours inquiet que lorsque
je fais des auditions parce que je dis
des choses comme ça
et oui mais il faut qu'on aille
peut-être plus loin si nous pouvons
aller plus loin sur ces questions et de
reconnaissance du patrimoine de la
nation de l'appartenance du ferroviaire
au patrimoine de la nation c'est
indispensable et ce sera peut-être une
demande des syndicats ce sera déjà une
demande alors sous quelle forme comment
nous de l'organiser avec vous
voilà alors sur les questions plus
sociales
d'abord j'écouterai ce que diront les
organisations syndicales ce soir et
demain je regarderai dans quelle mesure
il peut leur faire leur être apporté
réponse c'est vrai que ça n'est pas
simple mais je comprends aussi que
l'attente d'une garantie d'intégration
passe aussi par le niveau le plus élevé
de la reconnaissance sociale
mais lesquels amènent aussi parfois des
dérogations des règles qui sont
actuellement applicables en matière de
représentation des salariés donc faisons
le point mais nous anticipons et nous
avons anticipé pour
essayer d'apporter en tout cas des
orientations à des réponses sont pas les
rencontres boulevard Saint-Germain qui
se substitue aux travaux parlementaires
non plus donc il faut
que chacun ait bien conscience de son
rôle mais c'est un point qui n'est pas
fermé et qui doit nous permettre d'avoir
des lieux de
notamment comité central d'entreprise à
regarder puis les lieux de négociation
collectives quant au statut le statut
vous l'avez indiqué je l'ai rappelé
n'est pas mise en cause du tout
voilà ce que je peux apporter j'étais
suffisamment précis en réponse à
Monsieur testo monsieur le Président
sénateur
bien merci
monsieur le ministre à ce niveau de
discussion puisque nous étions entre
nous quand on voit la difficulté avec
laquelle on traite ce problème de la
dette
est-ce qu'on peut vous poser la question
de savoir où en est-on de cette écoute
c'est quand même il y a quand même un
peu d'argent là qui devrait être au
rendez-vous et deuxièmement
comment vous avez parlé de patrimoine
patrimoine mais comment a-t-on pu brader
le patrimoine autoroutier qui
aujourd'hui a un bénéfice de 2 milliards
est-ce que les organismes qui ont acheté
les banques etc ne pourraient pas faire
un effort ne peut-on pas faire de ce
problème là une un problème où tout le
monde apporterait sa contribution parce
que à coup de 500 millions par 600
millions par là entre nous soi-dis bon
puisque entre nous ça va durer un
certain temps et à raison de 500
millions par mois c'est quand même
effrayant donc moi je vous le dis très
sincèrement c'est pas mon habitude
j'interviens pas quand mes collègues
interviennent mais c'est 2 milliards
attendus donc de l'écotax il va bien
falloir que il y a une décision qui soit
prise en ce qui concerne le Sénat il y a
eu une discussion passionnée et féroce
mais on a trouvé un consensus sportif on
n'arrêtera pas à travers une enquête la
mise en oeuvre possible de l'écotaxe
dans le Sénat c'est prononcé dans des
difficultés qu'on avait rarement connu
mais finalement a pris ses
responsabilités en disant voilà il faut
donner la possibilité à l'état
d'appliquer cette écoute on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on en a absolument besoin
je vais répondre tout de suite parce que
c'est un sujet qui
inattendu non non pas inattendu du tout
parce que c'est vrai que dans le contrat
de plan d'ailleurs j'ai pas répondu sur
ce cette question là
contrat de plan est en région
il y a des financements qui viennent
évidemment des recettes attendues de
l'écotaxe il y a eu le débat
il est lointain le consensus il est
encore plus lointain et puis il y a eu
la responsabilité
c'est comment finance-t-on les
infrastructures
c'est mon obsession en obsession n'est
pas avoir une écotaxe pour les contacts
mon obsession n'est pas d'avoir honoré
absolument un contrat et como encore que
en tant que ministre de la République
la signature et la parole de l'État
doit amener à une forme de continuité
mais s'il y a négocié renégocier nous
l'avions engagé avant le remaniement
nous le poursuivons bien évidemment
voilà vous êtes donc pu suivre
l'audition de Frédéric Cuvillier le
secrétaire d'État au transport était
interrogé sur le projet de loi de
réforme ferroviaire tout de suite 24
heures Sénat présenté par Delphine
Girard